[Applause]
and the ball's on the
ground a
m snap was high and the kick is no
good a bad snap and they couldn't get
they really couldn't get the kick off oh
my amazing now third and three Williams
keeps it Caleb Williams to the 10 to the
five
touchdown time Noah faid throws over the
top cowing there touchdown that didn't
take long Jacob coing in the
slot fa looking middle and it's caught
touchdown and that is coow now quick
Tempo they get the ball snapped quickly
Jones up the middle
touchdown Williams rolling right Caleb
Williams is going to try to run now he
throws and it is incomp
complete the line goes left the ball
obviously stays put Williams gets the
ball snapped rolling right trying to get
there himself and I think he got out of
bound no they say he got
there under Center they pitch it left
Williams goes
down and
USC wins the game in triple
overtime